it's spring in Alaska the Bears are  awake and looking for food and one just  showed up at Andy passages remote  homestead come on girl you gotta stay  inside  damn bears walking up on me like Beth's  [ __ ]  you have to be cautious up here you're  on their turf all the time so you got to  be careful and you got to be vigilant  quite frankly they're intelligent  they're predatory and when they come out  of hibernation they're hungry why don't  you go early in the springtime up here  bears are our early meat it's the first  fresh meat that we see after a long  winter it's in the yard here so he's  going to be dinner tonight  the seam in the woods here and here in  the woods if Andy doesn't get the bear  right now it could return and take him  by surprise again  bad day for the bear good day for me